elle surgit de la vallée de l'ouche et
propose un voyage dans le temps cette
locomotive à vapeur date de 1938
[Musique]
cinq heures de travail ont été
nécessaires pour la démarrer aux
manettes pierre et son père gérard 15
ans qu'ils conduisent ces machines c'est
un rêve de gosse un petit peu sauf que
là bas voilà c'est là c'est le type de
geste métier qu'on fait revivre des
gestes qui ont plus de cent ans c'est
vrai plaisir à bord 50 passagers dont
beaucoup d'étrangers qui vivent cette
expérience unique à 15 km heure ça
change un peu l'italie s'est dite
désolée c'est sûr mais c'est surtout le
fait de se trouver coup les voilà donc
que c est guidé c'est quelque chose de
une époque différente
bien
la ligne reprend le trajet emprunté par
les pêcheurs au début du 20e siècle
depuis dijon elle permettait de rallier
les différents sites de la vallée
[Musique]
près d'un siècle plus tard les voyageurs
profitent à chaque arrêt des anecdotes
historiques du chef de train on a créé
ce train il ya trois ans pour justement
montrer l'histoire de la ligne parce que
si peu typique quand même ici l'histoire
de ce train
quelles sont ses trains comment ils sont
arrivés là puis l'avalé la région
travers de l'ouche et du canal de
bourgogne d'autres trains à vapeur
circulent sur la ligne les dimanches et
les jours fériés entre mai et septembre
de quoi embarquée pour d'autres voyages
dans le temps
[Musique]